personne n'y croyait mais elles sont
bien là les péniches de commerce sont de
retour dans les canaux du berry et du
loiret un défi énorme
un pari sur l'avenir à l'heure où les
nuisances provoquées par le fret routier
deviennent insupportables
tout commence ici à courre les bars à la
frontière entre la nièvre et le cher
avec cet homme
gilles morinie le patron des agrégats du
centre c'est lui qui a eu l'idée de
faire appel à des péniches pour
transporter le sable extrait tout près
d'ici jusqu'au port parisien de bonneuil
sur marne
un pari économique et écologique
l'image de notre profession a énormément
souffert pendant des années parce qu'on
pense carrière on pense camion poussière
bruit ce projet va permettre de montrer
que on fait aussi un paon suis un peu
l'évolution naturelle de ce qui se passe
maintenant est de faire 50 % de notre
production acheminés par bateau
ces douze mille camions en moins par an
c'est un bilan énergétique qui
travaillent à savoir que une péniche
dix sept fois moins pour le vendre qu'un
camion il y a plus de dix ans que les
péniches de commerce avait disparu du
canal alors pour les villages alentours
c'est un peu comme une renaissance
c'est merveilleux nos canaux revivons -
c'est impeccable avec le merveilleux
et puis au niveau écologique on est en
plein dedans aujourd'hui
cette semaine la presse bateaux font
l'aller retour entre le berry et la
région parisienne
la première étape nous emmène de court
les bars dans le cher à briare dans le
loiret par le canal latéral à la loire
aborde les lots yann guy et sa famille
vont remonter 240 tonnes de sable les
deux tiers de la cale mais le tirant
d'eau des petits canaux du cher ne
permet pas d'aller au-delà tous les
jours chargés par une interaction faire
d'autres paysages et la france sur un
autre essai pour ses paysages que
brigitte a quitté sa suisse natale pour
suivre ce fils de mariniers sédentaires
on a toujours la même vue au nouveau la
fenêtre on a toujours les mêmes voisins
on avait toujours le même jardin
hélas le jardin c'est la nature qui
défilent il ya toujours des autres 3 1
il ya des éclusiers il ya des gens très
changeant régulièrement ça c'est plutôt
sympa il y à la vie au dessus et la vie
en dessous le caresser le territoire des
enfants yannick 12 ans elodie 11 ans
hello et yann ont un emploi du temps
bien établie va le matin jp
je construis des voitures avec mais les
gros jeux sur la console
des fois je dessine
pas la même vie que les autres enfants
où tu as l'impression de
à voir
entière c'est quand même très différent
surtout parce que ben et surtout enfants
et
plus qu ils vont
l'école comme tout le monde
ben ali
des amis
bien sûr tout cas
sur les 300 km de trajet 78 écluses géré
par vnf voies navigables de france qui a
la responsabilité du réseau fluvial le
retour du fret
c'est un espoir pour les éclusiers dont
la profession est menacée
moi je suis assez content c'est mon
métier avant tout seul je pense à
l'avenir de mon métier longueur le
tourisme c'est bien il en faut et mais
bon je pense que le commerce peut
reporter encore c'est bien là pourquoi
la poule k nal moussy tout ça ça va
faire un flux du trafic
les péniches de type freycinet avec
leurs 5 mètres de large n'ont que
quelques centimètres de marche pour
loger dans les petites écluses du canal
latéral à la loire
bien sûr y est d'accord
c'est obligatoire pour le règlement
d'avoir deux cordées et stopper le
moteur les écuries gestion de ralenti
mais ne brille pas pour sk télé les
ouvrages des grands gabarits qui ne
laisse pas beaucoup de place aux petits
bateaux de plaisance très nombreux à cet
endroit ce qui occasionne parfois
quelques frayeurs
voilà on a eu beaucoup de chance qu'on a
croisé deux dans un tout petit mieux
fait ça c'est très impressionnant
on a toujours peur que la péniche vous
jette sur le rendement
pour les responsables de vnf
il est nécessaire de rappeler que le
fret est prioritaire en toutes
circonstances pour de bonnes raisons
je pense qu'il faut petit à petit
réfléchir à une mode d'exploitation qui
nous permettent de vraiment de nous
intégrer dans le développement du
territoire c'est à dire c'est pas
simplement sport le sait voir comment on
peut par l'exploitation développer des
commerces des services qu'on n'a pas
actuellement qui pourraient petit à
petit développer si on réfléchit aussi à
une un mode d'exploitation connu quand
on voit très bien quand on passe sur les
silos les coopératives agricoles
y a plus un seul bateau qui chargent du
grain alors que nous on va quand même
normal de voir le grain sur des bateaux
que sur des camions
face aux transports routiers guy aussi a
de bons arguments
autour nos moyens
du départ à la fin 1,6 à l'heure parce
qu'il veut dire si ça leur dit camion je
roule à 60 valeurs
wipro lui
depuis qu'on est là on me répond plus
loin à autre chose
développe on déplace la valeur vis
camion
ici aussi on se réjouit de la reprise du
fret sur le canal à marseille les
aubigny ont transformé jusqu'à présent
les vieille péniche freycinet en
logements aujourd'hui de nouvelles
perspectives s'ouvrent
on reste sur des bases on a massy le
traditionnel par contre j'ai évolué au
niveau des caractéristiques techniques
des bateaux haut niveau énergie au
niveau développement des bateaux haut
niveau au niveau normes aussi parce que
les normes ont changé on est on est sur
des nouvelles générations de mateur
niveau de la pollution
il y en a ouais
les doutes ont marqué à vienne devait
rentrer sur paris
d'accord
vivre sur un bateau c'est toute une
organisation
l'espace est réduit et la circulation
difficile
mais pour ce qui est de la cuisine
brigitte a trouvé ses repères
le problème c'est plus de courses que la
cuisine ne passait pas la taille de la
cuisine qui fait la différence
la proximité des épiceries donc nous on
a on en a pas quand on en europe
donc s'il me manque les merguez pour le
couscous il y en a pas pour faire 100
c'est l'heure du dîner le seul repas de
la journée qui réunit toute la famille
le lendemain est un jour particulier
même pour des mariniers chevronnés
les lots yann va passer le pont canal de
briare construit au 19e siècle au dessus
de la loire d'une longueur de 662 m il
est longtemps resté le plus long pour
canal du monde
il a été construit pour les bateaux de
commerce frais signer pour alimenter
paris c'est la première porte de paris
donc on a gagné du temps par rapport la
voirie à l'époque à la route et surtour
du fret
justement avec ces granulats qui remonte
sur paris s'est redynamisé la moto
c'est toujours la même émotion je vais
attendre qu'il passe devant la loi
j'aurai le nez du bateau la loire
derrière le pont canal le port de briare
et le plus important port de plaisance
de la région mais les installations ne
permettent pas pour l'instant le
stationnement des péniches de commerce
pour moi c'est une évidence que le canal
c'est une espace partagé c'est pour tout
le monde donc c'est pour le fret aussi
que pour les plaisanciers aussi que pour
les pêcheurs aussi que pour les gens qui
font du vélo etc
et je pense le fait que le fret va
revenir ça donne d'énergie et une
motivation pour entretenir mieux
entretenir réparer les voies d'eau donc
tout le monde va en profiter pour les
responsables de voies navigables de
france
ce retour du fret dans le bassin centre
bourgogne est aussi un véritable
challenge
il faut qu'on fournisse la preuve et
c'est tout à fait normal qu'on puisse le
faire avec des dotations tout à fait
raisonnable mais derrière on voit bien
que lorsqu'on va voir les collectivités
et qu'on leur parle de tout l'intérêt en
terme de formation d'emploi de retombées
économiques sur les territoires
traversés
on l'a forcément un regard qui disparaît
de ce qu'ils ont pu concevoir pendant
des dizaines d'années sur l'obsolescence
du transport fluvial
sur les lianes les boîtes écoles sont
sorties les enfants suivent les cours du
cned
le centre national d'enseignement à
distance et c'est brigitte ancienne
institutrice qui surveille les de voir
ça comme on joue pour qui c'était
presque une évidence parce que lui le
parti à l'intérieur quand il avait 6 ans
et pour un gamin de 6 ans est assez
lourde de quitter sa famille et de
d'être plongé dans la société comme ça
du jour au lendemain
c'est aussi con dans les mers en pension
c'est tous les week-ends il faut courir
pour la voiture on passe le week-end en
voiture au lieu de profiter des bons
moments ensemble
et
après avoir remonté le canal de briare
les lots yann navigue maintenant sur le
canal du loing est notre deuxième étape
va nous conduire de montargis à san
mamés dans le val de marne à la jonction
avec la scène malgré la volonté affichée
de développer le commerce fluvial la
profession de mariniers restent menacés
va faire 25 ans gervais nadeau
quarantaine d'années plus en plus
et puis à personne pour reprendre
derrière il n'ya pas la formation et
plus formation suffisante
les transports sont plus acérées
numérique donc un jeune combattant
investir une d'argent investies
tous les ans des gens qui par la
retraite et qui sont pas remplacés à
chaque passage des cluses
le personnel de vnf note le nom du
bateau le tonnage est la nature de la
cargaison qui serviront à calculer les
droits de péage sur le canal du loing où
le trafic commercial était en chute
libre
les péniches en provenance du berry sont
une chance
l'hiver on va dire qu'on a une trentaine
de péniches
on va dire tous les mois quoi qui vont
rarement target ou nemours
on ne saura pas plus ça aura plus de
travail mais bon c'est bien ça ramène du
fret et c'est très bien au bout du canal
du loing
derrière ce pont les bateaux rentrer en
scène et notre dernière étape nous
emmène de saint mamet à bonneuil en
empruntant le fleuve un bassin qui
concentre plus de la moitié du trafic
fluvial hexagonal un autre monde où l'on
croise des péniches de 135 mètres de
long et où les éclusiers sont perchés
dans des miradors
mais à bord de l'ailé yann la vie reste
la même et chaque membre de la famille
doit trouver sa place et son bonheur sur
les 40 mètres carrés de surface
habitable
pour que ça devienne pas étouffant il
faut le respect de tout le monde donc et
ça crée des liens
donc entre nous il ya des côtes qui soit
pas écrit mais dans le sens oui mais
maintenant il faut que je m'écarte je
prends mon coin et je laisse tranquille
donc vivre là c'est vivre c'est ça un
peu la philosophie de la famille le
dernier soir
les lots yann accostent sur les quais de
seine où guy doit déménager sa voiture à
l'arrière du bateau pour faciliter le
déchargement du sable le lendemain matin
direction le port de bonneuil en
bifurquant sur la marne
c'est la fin d'un voyage mais pour guy
l'essentiel est ailleurs
les fellahs du déplacement de la route
ou sabha je suis quand même plus cool
hein ce bois tôt le matin on se lève on
est sur place après transports en commun
pas de déplacements en voiture non je
sais très bien en plus appelés à ma
chérie donc les enfants sont les rois au
cidre si ça va tout le monde
tous
la france premier pays européen avec ses
8500 km de voies navigables n'en
exploite que le car loin derrière
l'allemagne ou la belgique
à 8 km de paris seulement le port de
bonneuil sur marne est un terminal
multimodal connecté au ferroviaire et à
la route et les 240 tonnes de sable
seront rechargées sur des camions
direction les chantiers de paris